on un peu corporatiste encore nous
impose que normal tout un ensemble de
trousseau de statut on obligé d'avoir la
blouse blanche et bien par des visions
on décide de faire la grande manif du 13
mai en blouse blanche et est tous les
lits nono comme on les appelait les
descendent où un bus blanc ces jours-là
de 13 mais moi ça m'a particulièrement
marqué parce que mon père qui est
gendarme sur valentigney il est mobilisé
à besançon et le matin du 13 mai ya un
gendarme tout 1 h et qui via l'entrée
l'école normale les copains d attention
ça y est on vient vous arrêter et puis
c'est mon père qui viens m'embrasser
quoi ça c'est assez étonnant c'est et
l'étonnant nuit par mon action mon
frangin même moment un travail chez
peugeot him
il est dans les pick and roll chez
peugeot on pert est menacée déduirez
quoi y'a jamais progresser dans jade
maya cause de ça allait payer les
conséquences des îles rapide et
conséquente seriez dîner des remarques
et il était simplement devenu roi c'est
son fils quoi c'est tout doc sait où
elle est copain ému parce que dira la
rater vos pas manifester cet après midi
on risque de se retrouver en face des
gendarmes qui gendarmes on les a pas vus
sur l'accord mais mais c'est vrai que
c'était c'était cd prégnant